we don't have to like our jobs every day
we get to love them every day we don't
have to like it every day you don't like
your kids every day you love them every
day sure that's right and and I think
this we sort of have this
the sort of rejection of discomfort
these days you know what everybody has
to be made to feel comfortable all the
time and at the end of the day
discomfort is part of Being Human
um you know go back like bad weather is
being out of the rain it's uncomfortable
so
um you know how we manage that line
because there is a line where
um that there is too much
but uh but there's also too little so I
think you know in terms of uncomfortable
conversations
um or or or when companies are trying to
find their pacing and When leaders make
mistake make mistakes it doesn't mean
they're bad people we have to remember
that uh it's the behavior or the or the
skill set that that we're labeling not
the person